Aliza Roden Eliza Eliza and she said in
the age of computers and smartphones
does anyone really need to learn cursive
handwriting anymore I was recently
talking to a friend about this who said
that he recently saw cursive written
down somewhere and he kind of had
trouble even reading it because it had
been so long since he ever had to read
cursive never mind write cursive I
remember when I came to the United
States in first grade we started
learning letters and you would have
these lined pieces of notebook paper and
you would do your capital print a and
then your lowercase print a and then
right below that you would do your
Capitol cursive a and then your
lowercase cursive a and you would learn
to write cursive and already then people
were saying at I remember asking my
parents and different people you know
now that we have word processors at the
time it was you know the early age of
personal computing earlier age when am I
really going to need to write cursive
and it was always if you need to write a
letter to someone if you need to write a
thank-you note to someone etc etc and it
was like okay that kind of makes sense I
really don't know now whether writing
cursive is a relevant thing like
shouldn't you be teaching print writing
and typing insightly as opposed to
cursive I don't know I don't know oh
absolutely and I think even before the
advent of computers cursive was already
a dying art because we had typewriters
right before that true you know the
whole handwritten thank-you card letter
it's nice when you get it every once in
a while but the vast majority of the
time we're just communicating by text or
email so is this really worth dedicating
our time to I know I spent maybe a year
or two learning cursive in English
classes in grade school if I was to
learn typing I'd be much better at that
now I think and that's a skill that I
use every day I never use cursive so I
just figure out what the generational
divide is if I asked you what letter in
cursive capitals looks like the number
two q oh okay all right so you're not
you're not a total one you got totally
out of it okay good question yeah I
don't know that we really even when I
write a thank you note because I worry
that the recipient might be unaccustomed
to curse
I will write I will print when I write a
thank you know I mean some people just
have handwriting that's illegible anyway
right or yeah because they've chicken
scratch whatever now I'm having a tough
time tough time remembering what the X
looks like incur Civ what does the X
look like ah I go back and cross it I
think you do I think an X a capital X in
cursive looks sort of like in ads like
an algebra yeah I always you know
crossing the T's and dotting the eyes
with such a pain because you'd get
through that whole word the Nance go
back I mean it just doesn't seem very
efficient yeah see this is this is the
prop this is what I'm talking about this
is I mean that's not the way I would I
would think about that wouldn't be a
good reason not to write in cursive okay
but okay iliza I am ready to say in 2017
that although it's a nice little skill
to have I don't think it's really
necessary to learn cursive anymore I am
ready to declare a cursive dead I
predict a lot of angry emails about that